Hello and welcome back. Children, today we are going to learn measurement
of an angle. How to measure an angle. So are
you guys ready? Let us begin. Such Au
and P who are playing a game with math sticks. They are making different
angles using math sticks. Let us see such children.
First, it is P whose turn she says, let me play first.
And she makes an angle using the the mat sticks.
Okay, now these mat sticks are bigger so that you can see
it. Generally the mat sticks are smaller. Okay. So this angle
is created by P Who. But how to measure this
angle? Children, do you know how to measure this angle? Let us see.
So first of all, is this acute or is
this Obtuse? Children, let us see my hand here.
Suppose this is right angle. L shape
less than L shape. This is acute. More than
L shape. Obtuse. Yes. So this one is
this one is less than L shape. This is
acute angle. Okay. Now one more thing you need to measure.
This is a protractor. This you will find in
your geometry boxes. Now you can
see in the protractor there are two type of numbers
written here. 50 is written. I'll zoom in a
little bit here. 50 is written and 130 is written.
Now children, you just now saw that this is an acute
angle. Acute angle also mean less than 90.
So children, which one will I choose? 130 or 50
which is less than 90? Yes, you are absolutely correct.
50 is the correct answer for this one.
So children, here the measure of this angle
is 50 degrees. Now let us see
what IU has to do. Now it's my turn, says IU.
So again, using two mat sticks, he makes another angle.
Again, children, how to measure this angle? What is the first
step? We need to check if this is acute or Obtuse.
Again, children, this is less than L shape. Less than
L shape. So this is acute. Now let us put the
protractor here. This protractor is also D
shaped. Can you see? This is D shape. Yes.
Now look at the protractor. Once again, you can
see 70. You can see 110. Since this
is acute, this is less than 90. Which one will I
choose? Yes, children, I will choose the 70.
So IU made an angle of 70
degrees. So this is what P who. And IU made.
Now let us try some more examples. Look at this one. Children,
first step, what do we need to check? Is this acute or optus?
This is more than more than L shape.
More than 90. This is optus. So we will
put the protractor. Now here it is 30.
Here it is 150. Look here. Here it is 30.
Here it is 150. So which one will I choose?
This is Obtuse angle more than 90. So I
will choose the other one. I will choose 150.
In this case. Okay, children, one more example very quickly.
Come on. This is less than L shape again.
This is less than L shape again. So this is acute angle.
Let's put the protractor here. Now, children,
again I'll zoom in. So this is acute less
than 90. So will I choose 50 or will I choose 130? Which one,
children? Yes. Very good. I will choose the
50 again. So in this case the correct answer is
50 degrees. That's all from my side. Children,
you all find out more such interesting angles and see
me next time. Until then,